vi ritrovate ben trovati oggi sono qui
per parlare della capacità della
necessità di metterci in gioco perché
dico necessità perché mettersi in gioco
non è una città così facile significa
uscire dal territorio che ci fa sentire
sicuri e rinunciare all'abitudine le
routine che ci danno l'illusione di
avere tutto sotto controllo che compiere
un balzo sorretti da capacità che non
siamo poi così sicuri vi posso dire è
come se questo non fosse già difficile
dobbiamo farlo sotto lo sguardo altrui
quindi rischiando di essere oggetto del
giudizio degli altri
ho 44 anni ormai quasi quattro anni fa
la mia vita è completamente cambiata è
arrivata la grande occasione è arrivata
la proposta di pubblicazione del mio
primo romanzo da un editore molto
importante anch'io mi sono trovata
davanti alla decisione se compiere quel
balzo accettare che la mia vita
cambiasse completamente per tentare di
afferrare un grande sogno non è stato
facile decidere nonostante il mio sogno
fosse lì me lo stessero per consegnare
perché non è così facile perché il
cervello ci porta in tutt'altra
direzione
il cervello e pragmatico tende a
semplificarci la vita e quindi ci
indirizza verso le decisioni che rendono
più comoda la nostra esistenza di
ingegneria degli oggetti quotidiani si
basa su questo assunto nella nostra vita
di tutti i giorni tendiamo ad utilizzare
l'oggetto più semplice questo
funzionante per i nostri pensieri in
serie che poi si devono tradurre i
decisioni e combinazioni che cosa
succede che andò quando la nostra vita
tempo
su una serie di decisioni che la rendono
più facile quindi la lontana non dal
rischio dal cambiamento della grande
rivoluzione nulla di male si può vivere
un'intera esistenza in questo modo ed
essere comunque felice però qui arriva
la brutta notizia quando abbiamo un
grande sogno
quando abbiamo una grande visione per il
nostro futuro ecco difficilmente questo
grande sogno e questa gran visir si
troveranno a portata di mano se restiamo
immobili la vita ci chiede quel passo in
più ci chiede il cambiamento la grande
rivoluzione non è facile accettarlo
perché l'equilibrio difficile
conquistare da mantenere non è stato
facile nemmeno per me io poi vi parlo da
grande ex timida nonché la timidezza ne
abbia del tutto abbandonato però ho
imparato a gestirla ho imparato tante
cose anche su di me in questi anni la
timidezza mi ha accompagnato per gran
parte della mia vita e la modellata la
modellata sulla base anni tante piccole
paure dei tanti timori che mi hanno
fatto perdere ora mi rendo conto anche
diverse occasioni magari non grandissime
magari solo quotidiane perso quindi
questa grande proposta che mi è arrivata
l'estate in campo perché mi chiedevano
di cambiare la mia vita avrebbe dovuto
cambiare da subito
avrei dovuto interagire quotidianamente
con figure professionali anche di spicco
nel panorama editoriale italiano quindi
figure che potevano crearmi soggezione
avrebbe dovuto parlare in pubblico e non
ero sicura di poterlo fare non ero
sicura mi volevo farmi voler fare quello
sforzo che per me era e probabilmente
reagire poi quotidianamente con
direttori editoriali
niente dovevo viaggiare spesso da sola
per la promozione del libro interagire
con i blogger giornalisti lettori le
lettrici tutto questo vi sembrava troppo
grande per me troppo impegnativo
manualità era in equilibrio quasi
perfetto
la famiglia si stava per ingrandire
avevo un lavoro che definirei dietro le
quinte che quindi mi teneva al sicuro
dal confronto con gli altri ma un
confronto come stessa quello che temevo
di più con le risorse le mie capacità
che cosa ho fatto l'amore per la
scrittura era troppo grande queste paure
a un certo punto dovuto accantonare e
fare quel balzo a distanza di anni in
guarda indietro e posso dire di essere
cresciuta a secondo sogno perché ho
imparato tante cose sugli altri ma
soprattutto su me stessa ho imparato che
i limiti che vedevo attorno a maiden
opposti io stessa ed erano dei limiti
psicologici era la paura a tenere
lontana dalla mia grande visione del
futuro
a un certo punto del cammino qualcuno
tenterà di ingannarvi e successo anche a
me tenterà di farlo perché probabilmente
a sua volta è stato ingannato riparlerà
di spirito di competizione in iraq e li
dovrete se dirlo a sentirlo fortemente
per riuscire ad eccellere se deciderete
di credergli comincerete a vedere gli
altri attorno a voi come dei nemici
dovrete sgomitare per ottenere
per ciò che vorrete perché crederete ad
un mondo ad un ambiente di risorse
scarse per cui lottare
ecco l'ansia inizierà a crescere
e questa sia porterà via tempo ed
energie ai pensieri costruttivi alle
intuizioni potenti che potrebbero
rendere voi stessi nel vostro lavoro
unici e necessario per qualcun altro se
deciderete di credergli soprattutto
avrete già perso perché per quanto
possiamo fare al mondo ci sarà sempre
uno più bravo di noi
e allora come possiamo reagire come
possiamo rispondere possiamo decidere di
giocare la partita secondo le nostre
regole spostarci dal piano competitivo
dove le risorse sono scarse
quello creativo dove le occasioni siamo
noi a crearne con l'intuizione con
l'estro creativo con le emozioni con il
confronto con la condivisione con tutta
una serie di atteggiamenti positivi e
costruttivi che sull'agro piano non
possono esistere delle sinergie
potentissime che ci sfugge rebbero
altrimenti di mano tenete sempre
presente la vostra passione
restate concentrati non nego che i
momenti difficili ci sono e ci saranno
ci sarà tanta stanchezza a volte e
frustrazione perché stessi risultati
hanno bisogno di tempo per
concretizzarsi
durante il cammino per diventare
scrittrice i compagni di avventura che
avevano lo stesso sogno dicevano alcuni
di loro dicevano voglio vedere il mio
nome sulla copertina di un libro voglio
essere primo prima in classifica non
voglio diventare famoso
ecco tutti questi pensieri buono sempre
spaventata in cercato di tenerli lontani
perché li vedevo quasi nefasti e adesso
capito perché
perché non parlano di passioni non
parlano di sentimento non parlano della
gioia che avere un sogno di rivelare
anche durante il cammino per realizzare
non solo quando lo ottieni la passione
non ti celebra la passione ti stende il
tappeto di piede di rialzarci di farlo
in fretta
ti chiede di lavorare ti chiede tutto il
progetto richiede impegno richiede
energie richiede dedizione e sacrificio
per sé saprei esserle fedele restarle
fedele con duro lavoro
alla fine ti consegnerà altro sogno
grazie